[Music]  you're frightened of your nature  and promises they escape you  was one more burden on the back of this  beast  when i can take back all the hurt i've  caused  and everything i love i have somehow  lost  and it's four in the morning  and the spiders are crawling  [Music]  [Music]  is it a stain on your conscience  or is it more like a mural  a memorial for all those you try to be  and is it how you imagined it  in the great wide open  all you've left unspoken now just  hanging in the breeze  cause i can take back all the hurt i've  caused  everything i love i have somehow thought  and it's four in the morning  and the spiders are crawling  [Music]  i'm trying  but  [Music]  love  [Music]  so soon  my own  friends  i hope that i'll never see you  again  [Music]  [Laughter]  i'm trying  but i can't pull myself  [Music]  i  [Music]  comes  [Music]  you